my council be seated for a second has a
couple things that i need to address
all right number one uh juror number
fourteen
yes uh i i was informed first by the
officer and then by my staff at the
break that at some point during the
cross examination
you were able to see a document that was
up on one of the prosecutor's screens is
that an accurate
statement
right okay and you saw it directly or
was it reflected off of one of the
dividers
well
early on i saw a photograph right off
the fire
and
subsequently i saw a document
yes all right
all right and i've i've instructed pride
it's unfortunate this is covered era and
you are seated where you are normally
you'd be in the box and you wouldn't be
able to see anything so i i've
instructed the prosecutors at sidebar
when it was first brought to my
attention to be very careful about that
so
if there's something that's going to be
shown to the witnesses
on the screen they'll pull that up but
otherwise they shouldn't pull up
documents and if they happen to pull
something up just try not to look at it
to the best of your ability okay and uh
fine that should um handle the situation
now the other situation is i was
informed by my staff that some of the
jurors in the second row may have heard
whispering coming from the gallery
that's completely unacceptable
not that the jurors heard it but there's
whispering in the gallery people in the
gallery cannot talk about the case
especially
because we have jurors in the first two
rows
and members of the jury thank you for
bringing that to my staff's attention if
it persists i will have my courtroom
cleared
do i make myself clear
please do not discuss any aspect of the
case
do not speak about the case do not speak
about anything that may distract our
jurors
when you are in the courtroom
if there is another complaint i will
exercise my authority and clear the
courtroom except for the jurors i don't
want to have to do that this is a public
courtroom a public trial
you have a right to be here but
the jurors have a right not to be
distracted
by whispering in the courtroom they have
to pay careful attention and they have
been throughout this trial and i have no
doubt they will continue to pay
attention
to what occurs in the courtroom from the
witness stand but they cannot be
distracted
by members of the public in the gallery
so please do not speak at all about the
case you should be saying nothing
just listen to the testimony
if you have comments that's fine i'm
sure you all do share them outside
outside the presence of the members of
the jury
all right thank you all right with that
being said can we bring in mr goodwin
please and we'll continue with the
cross-examination
the members of the jury please if you
hear anything just bring it to my
staff's attention and raise your hand
and i'll deal with it immediately all
right thank you
[Music]
good morning
before we proceed i'm sorry can i see
council on sidebar for one moment please
the continued cross-examination of mr
goodwin
go ahead council
[Music]
that's a good one
you testified
that
you
saw the actual
shooting
of foreign correct yes
did you
previously tell
corporal thomas fellini
that after you talked to michael
barrisson
you turned
to walk back
into the residence
then
lauren cataract
walked over
to speak to michael bauerstown judge can
we come to sidebar
uh reword and clarify your questioning
of the witness please
mr goodwin
after the shooting did you talk to the
washington township police department i
did
did you give them a statement
right after the incident as to what
actually happened i did give a statement
did you tell the washington township
police department
that after you spoke to michael
barrisson you turned your back and
walked into the house to walk back into
the
house that's this is the problem mr
blinkus
why don't you show it to him and ask the
witness if that's what he said to the
police
that's why i said that
all right please proceed
this is a good one i'm going to show you
defense exhibit
100 c 14.6
which is an affidavit
i'm going to refer you to page four
and point out a
a portion that's big enough thank you
all right and ask you
to read that
to see if it refreshes the recollection
as to what you specifically told the
police
immediately after the incident this is a
transcript of the
recorded it's an f
affidavit
it's a sworn statement submitted by the
police
that is not accurate
so is it your testimony that you never
told
the police
immediately after the incident that
after you talked to michael barrisson
you've walked into the residence and
heard gunshots
that doesn't say i walk into the
residence it says
what's important in that thing is that
it says that i did the witness not
comment on
what's contained in a police document
now
you observed warren cataract
walking to michael barrason is that your
testimony correct
and
did you hear what laurent cataract said
to michael barrasso
she said she would talk to him and as
she was walking
i'm asking what she said to him not you
i think she
started to say something and then
michael reached
pulled the gun out and shot her
when you say he
reached weren't you still
weren't you still blocked by that huge
bush and could only see from his chest
up as you've testified to
so the other day he stepped forward and
reached out his arms before he shot
lauren
so
no
did you see him on the telephone
excuse me did you see him on the
telephone at any point
no
did you see
michael barisson's
phone on a table
in that general area at any point
i saw a gun in michael's hands no phone
and when did you see this gun
when you
pulled it up and shot barn now
you said michael barrasson's about six
three six four okay
and you were standing on the label how
far up on his body could you see him
from that location
i think
chest chest up
maybe maybe a little higher okay so
we're about from here to me somewhere
about sorry and it's your testimony that
he picked
the weapon up
high enough for you to see it over that
bush
and fire two shots into lauren
counteract
as long as approaching michael to have
this conversation that michael
said he wanted to have with us
he took a step forward towards lauren
raised up his hands and shot so
his arms
were
understand what i'm saying he stepped
out from behind the bush at that point
he took one step from behind the bush
when he shot
he was aggressively well not
aggressively sorry took a step towards
lauren when he took the shot when he
raised up the gun all right so let me
see if i understand what you're saying
if you're on
the porch
the bushes
approximately what eight feet away from
where you're standing
and
it's
as high as michael barrasson's chest
correct
okay and even though you're elevated you
only see
from here up correct okay
now
it's your testimony
from that position
that michael barrasson takes the step
out to my right towards the gravel
driveway okay towards lauren where she
was standing
and
raises his hand and shoots her okay
now how tall is lauren cataract
five five five six okay well can i
assume he didn't raise the gun up this
high to shoot at lauren cataract over
five five i think that would be pretty
accurate yeah okay and
he
and this is based on what you're
testifying you saw the gun was about
where when he fired the shots that
like straight out from his arm as i'm
holding it
approximately four feet correct
props
how
high was his arm raised
since he raised his hand he extended his
arm
and you could see that
over the bush
do we have a picture i'll show of
he stepped one step
forward out one step forward out to the
driveway which was enough to be
unconcealed by the bush 100
and i don't know if that bush was there
if it would block his arms because like
i said i definitely could see his
shoulders i saw his arms come up when he
he talked to me when he came up to talk
to me so
if he held his gun up
you know i think it'd be pretty
reasonable to say
that i saw it still if he stood in the
exact same position he tried to lure us
out of the house in from
when you say
lure
us out of the house
you and both lauren came out on your
free will correct
i think he tried to pull us
to his area i came out to the porch i
did not want to conversate with him i
told him the attorneys will handle it
i believe his intention was to pull us
out of the house
i asked you
when you first observed michael
barrasson
if you would describe him as sorrowful
and
he didn't even
seem like you understood what i
was asking is that a fair statement
yes i did not recall it i don't know and
also you were very vague about it was he
sorrowful within the two years that i've
ever met him i had no contact no no i'm
talking about i didn't know that moments
before
the shooting
i'm talking about the day of the
incident
did you tell the police in your official
version he looked really
sorrowful
page four bottom of the first paragraph
where is it at
page four bottom of the first paragraph
you need my glasses or no i could do
this
okay
did you describe
your observations of michael barrisson
immediately before the shooting as
sorrowful
it says here i did and
do you recall that
i don't recall saying this no
i left this statement when lauren was
dying in the hot well when i thought
lauren was dying in the hospital or
possibly not alive okay and at that
point
is it fair to say that you had no love
loss for michael barrisson and you
weren't saying anything trying to
protect him what is fair to say is i
think this is consistent with what i'm
saying is
sincere sorrowful he tried to draw us
out of the house
to him so he could shoot us
you say i could only see from the chest
and above and he said something like he
looked really sorrowful you know
what did you just say you believe that
to me
he looks sincere in saying how do we
work this out
i personally did not care because
but
my
specific question is
did you use the term
sorrowful
it says right here i said sorrowful i
agree
so
will you agree with me that
calm
and
sorrowful is a huge difference between
angry
i never said he was angry
and would you agree with me that based
on your entire observations
the entire incident
he never appeared angry correct
correct we just went over this yes
now
you just testified on
uh to my last question that you observed
michael barrasson shoeborn cataract
from the landing on top of the stairs
correct
correct
i was on landing
did you tell the police in your official
statement that before the shooting you
came down the stairs
came down the stairs from before the
shooting yes i was upstairs on the third
floor apartment i imagine i came down
some stairs
can you look at page three
is it your
testimony that your reference to the
police that you came down the stairs
that you were talking about
inside
of the house at that point
is that your sworn testimony
i believe that's in reference to me
coming down the stairs from the
apartment
well when you said lauren walked down
the stairs where was she walking down
the stairs
in that
specific
sentence
where was lauren when you were walking
down the stairs was she outside at that
point
she was behind me
oh
and then she agreed with me that
you told the police she walked down the
stairs to talk to barista
and then two shots
were fired
isn't it a fact you were inside when the
shots were fired not at all fact
it's ridiculous
now
how quickly were these shots fired in
succession
very quickly yeah stop watch
boom boom
okay and then
how quickly after that
was the shot you playing was fired at
you
took two three more steps turned to me
and fired at me so a couple of seconds
okay so some sort of a pause in between
the two two two shots fired lauren
a little hesitation
maybe a pause whatever you want to call
it aimed at me and fired at me okay
boom
boom
boom boom boom boom
now
were those shots live
uh not overly no i don't think so
i mean they were loud yes but
nine millimeter correct
yeah it's gonna be a reference question
right
well you're familiar with nine
millimeters
was it a loud boom
uh was it wasn't as loud as uh
lauren's gone
did you tell the police that after
he fired at lauren
that you ran
in
the house
did you tell the police that immediately
after the incident
sorry can you rephrase it or can you say
it again sure did you tell the police
that after
lauren was shot
i kind of ran
in the house
did you say that
i dove into the in into the door as
michael raised the gun up at me
did you say i've ran in the house
again a second time in your official
statement
i dove into the house i dove into the
house i remember seeing the
tempered glass windows shattering around
the floor as i
was laying on the floor so
if i didn't maybe it was a misspeak
i'm sure throughout here we'll find out
do i have to read this
i'm not if i ask you a question or refer
to
refer you to a specific section
now
you see lauren gets shot
isn't it a fact that after she got shot
she ran away
and you have no idea where she went
i did lose contact when i dove into the
house of where she went yes
and
did she run around the house
based on your observations
she ran away when michael after michael
shot at her she turned around
ran away
pretty shortly after he raised the gun
at me and i dove into the house so i did
not
see
if one right now in the house
did you ever tell anyone
that lauren disappeared
and you think she ran around the house
i don't know what lauren did after i
dove in the house
well
you weren't in the house for any length
of time correct i dove on the floor and
i got up and i charged out at that time
michael was charging in okay and
was lauren there in the immediate area
at that point lauren was there because
on the conflict on the porch when
michael brought the gun up and i had him
in a choke hold
she grabbed his gun hand and tried to
pull it down i assume
i assumed he was going to try to
shoot at me over his head over his
shoulder
but lauren jumped on his arm and held
his gun hand
now
did you ever tell the police that
lauren cataract
was up on the stairs
grabbing at michael barissone's arm with
a weapon in it in your official
statement
i would imagine i did say that
can you look at uh page three
same paragraph you're talking to i'm
talking about
and see whether or not it refreshes your
recollection as to whether you ever
mention
that lauren cataract and you
were on the stairs
trying
to get the gun away from michael barista
so
so
so
okay
not in that paragraph it does not say
that
when you say paragraph
that's the paragraph when you talk about
the actual shooting correct
the paragraph i just read
and nowhere in there did you mention
that lauren cataract was on the steps
struggling with you and
she wasn't on the steps
she reached up while me and mike were on
steps she was on the side
side of the railing she reached up tried
to grab michael's arm
from with her feet on the ground i
thought she could have been on the steps
she was behind michael
she was
it was me michael lauren i saw lauren
jump up and grab his hands i don't know
exactly where she was standing okay but
you you testified previously she was on
the steps correct
i'm not entirely sure that's accurate
all right also that's good again
where exactly when was laurent cataract
where
you say she reached up and tried to grab
michael barrison
she was on the
would be michael's front side
on the other end of me and michael
all i saw were her hands
and that they were
wrapped around his arm as he was trying
to
pull it up she was trying to pull his
arms down
and
again i don't want to belabor this point
anymore but you don't know whether she's
on the steps or she's on the ground
i was concentrating on the gun that was
coming up to my head okay and when when
you're talking about this specific
instance michael barrisson is
his back is to you correct correct
lauren canorack is front is
[Music]
this question yes
and did you knock them out
with that punch
no
so
at some point in time
when the gun
according to you is in michael
barrasso's hand
both you
and lauren are struggling with him
to try to get the gun correct
no
i was struggling to
stop him from
murdering us
okay well
you saw the slide back
and immediately recognize that the gun
was empty before
you leaped out and struck and struck him
according to your testimony correct
so there was no danger in any other
bullets being fired
based on your observations of michael
barrasso
and the gun
i don't know if i was able to process i
don't know if i was able to process
what was going on i was very unfamiliar
with the gun i did not
you know i did not know the full extent
of processing it i mean i watched lauren
get shot
and yet i didn't realize she was shot
until i saw the holes coming out of the
back of her shirt so it's a very
stressful fast time
we'll get to that point in a second but
let's talk about
something else first
you say
you physically see
not hear but physically see
michael barrisson shoot lauren cameron
correct
and and it's your testimony that with
that observation
you didn't even realize
that she was shocked
is that your testimony
even though you claim to have seen a gun
heard
the gunfire twice
you did not realize
until after you started beating michael
barrison that he was shot she was shot
is that your testimony
she did not let me rephrase it this way
she did not fall on the ground after
being shot
there is a possibility that maybe she
was missed
we get those possibilities out of the
way when i'm looking at holes coming
through the back of her shirt
that is when i realized she was shot by
michael
now
you'll agree with me when
you
leaped at michael barroso and
cracked him in the face
that that was the first
punch that you landed
now
didn't michael barriston have his back
to you at that point
no he was charging into the house and
was leaping out of the house
when did he turn his back on you
well after i punched him he looked dazed
for a little bit and then
i didn't know her just turned and went
to go
run off i don't know if he was what he
where he was running to
what he was doing i don't know what he
was thinking
he turned around
and i don't know if he was retreating or
walking he turned around and gave me his
back
and
where exactly
on michael barrasson's face did you
strike him
i think the forehead
when he turned his back and attempted
to get away
is that when you
leaped on his back and started to choke
him
i'm sorry i just i just said i don't
know what he was doing so i'm not saying
that he attempted to get away he could
have been going to finish
killing lauren
there's nothing
that states he was trying to get away he
was a man with a gun on our property
trying to kill us
i subdued him
okay so
at some point
irrespective of what his intentions are
he tries to
walk away from correct he turned around
turned around
and at that point you jump on his back
and you start choking him at that point
i threw a chokehold right on his neck
and
is he still on the stairs at this point
we're either on the patio
i think we're right on the top not the
patio sorry the um
porch
the little porch we're on
top of the porch at that point
maybe one step down i don't know
we're on the porch
so
you're on the landing
or the first step going down
okay that's what your testimony is yeah
so
is it
safe to assume that when you struck him
in the forehead
he was on the landing
by his car
did he attempt to turn
and walk away
while he was still on the landing
turned around
okay and started to walk down
and only got to the first step correct
according to what you just said i feel
like we're having a play on words here
say it again i i just want to try to be
accurate
you indicated
he's on the landing and you you hit him
in the forehead
he turns around
he's still on the landing
and he's either on the landing or he's
taking his first step down and you jump
on him and start choking him correct
yeah as soon as he turned around i was i
was on his neck okay as
you gotta remember this is a fight for
my life lauren's life
right so
okay as soon as he turned around i tried
to subdue him okay and where was lauren
at this point when he's at the top of
the stairs
trying to
grab at the gun
next time i see lauren is when the gun
comes up lauren jumps on his arm
to protect me
at that point we don't know the gun is
jammed
or anything
of the fact like i said
even seeing it i did not recognize it
did not process in my head
that that gun was no longer a weapon
because the slide was locked back
didn't you tell the police that
the reason why you decided to
charge at michael barrasson is because
you saw that the slide was back and
realized that the weapon had no bullets
in it
please show me where i was set anywhere
we'll get to that
[Music]
now
when you were choking michael barristone
um
did he pass out
he did
and where's
lauren cataract at that point
lauren counteract is on the side of the
stairs
well we're all grouped in one section if
you got a picture that's easier if i
just show you that explain
now at this point in time were you down
on the concrete patio
i was on top of michael and we were both
on the patio
did you
slam michael barrisson's
face
into the concrete patio
we passed out we fell onto the patio
onto the concrete patio
any point in time did in the struggle
did you
punch him
in the face
when michael was coming back too he was
very
he was trying to get back up i did punch
him
and i did hold him down how many times
did you punch michael barrasson in the
face
enough to get him to not get access to
the gun anymore do you have any idea how
many
punches that took
i mean this is a fight for my life so
was i concerned about how many times i
was punching the man that is trying to
get up
i was not and i
no i do not know how many times i
punched him in the face
the fact of the matter is he was trying
to get back up and did you
punch him
on the side of the head
in both ears
specifically i do not know
have you seen any pictures of
what michael barrasson looked like
after you got done punching him and
hitting him
i saw him on his first court hearing
now
at some point in time did lauren
cataract
start
beating michael
on the side of the face
with her telephone lauren carrick may
have hit him a few times
at that point she was just about to pass
out
and it's your testimony
go ahead
i did
want her to
you know
want her to stay alive is is
you know
i don't know if my focus was that sh
she just maybe can press
or hold the blood in i didn't you know i
would
prefer that's what what she was would be
doing you know okay but
did she
beat michael barristone
for approximately seven minutes
during this incident no
how many times did you see lauren
cataract
hit michael barissone
with her telephone
in the ear
and the cheek area
a few times i've seen lauren she was
also in the fight for her life
okay
she hit him a few times but at this
point she was very
very close to passing out
and she couldn't even stand
so i do not believe there was any sort
of
damage done
from her hitting she may think
she did some damage you may imply that
you did some damage but at this point
she was almost dying
okay incapable of
of
walking around at this point correct at
this point she was on the ground yes
incapable of walking up the stairs and
uh
getting an object from the landing
correct
we're talking about after i subdued
michael
yes you're talking you're implying
before no before i'm not implying before
listen to my question
your testimony and correct me if i'm
wrong is that
immediately after the shooting
you strike michael
he turns his back you choke him
you fall to the patio area
and you start to subdue him correct
that's correct
and lauren kenorak is there the whole
time
on her knees
correct
from when i had michael on the ground
and we all we all fell
right yes she is right there with us
she's right there with you and she
starts
hitting her with the phone
you saw that correct i just said that
okay
um
do you know how she got
her phone to hit michael barrathon
which wasn't
available to her at that point
yeah mr blink don't editorialize please
just ask ask the question do you know
do you know
i know just re-ask the question and
don't editorialize just ask a question
did you see lauren cataract
leave the area
walk up the stairs
grab her iphone
come down
and then start beating
michael barrison
she never left that that area correct
at that point like i stated she was
pregnant time
okay
and can i assume that after that
you didn't see her go back up the stairs
again
and get a different phone
and come down
and call 9-1-1
she had my phone
from the minute i walked down the stairs
from the apartment correct did i give it
to her either mr valenkas again
you know we don't need your comments
about the testimony it's it's
inappropriate you don't say correct when
a witness answers don't do it again
please
she had your phone when she came to talk
to michael barriston correct
she definitely had my phone yes and this
whole shooting the sequence of events
would
be heard by the lawyer who was on the
call
correct
i assume yes
and
after you
struck michael and choked him
she was down on her knees
close to dying
the entire time correct from that point
on yes until the police showed up
you never saw her and correct me if i'm
wrong
her going up the stairs once or twice
to get something
no
she wasn't even capable of doing that
based on your observations of her
medical condition correct
correct
yes
now
did you see
lauren cataract running around in a
circle at any point
assume we're talking about the incident
i do not
i do not recall her running in a circle
i recall her running away from
michael
and when i say run away i saw a few
steps before michael aimed a gun at me
and i dove inside so
at any point during this incident did
michael barry barrisson say anything to
you
after your initial discussion with them
no
now
when you were subduing michael barrison
you tell the police
that you didn't think he knew where he
was
at that point or words to that event
after i punched him or after he was
choked out
after he was choked out
and every year
i mean
no he was he was choked out and then
when he was coming back to consciousness
is when he was
moving around and trying to get up
anything further mr belinkas yes church
i've just got over my notes
um
did you tell the police immediately
after this incident that
you thought michael's barisone had
psychological problems objection
that was true
the objections sustained mr goodwin
at any time
during this incident
did you observe
anything that would indicate that
michael barrasson was having
psychological problems objection
it's the same question in a different
point right and it was dressed up but um
focusing on it the question
is not we know you're not an expert
all right so
council is just asking what observations
you made about
the defendant
um
i'm not really too sure i answered the
question
all right ask another question mr
balancas
um
now
with regards to your observations of
michael before the shooting
you've already testified that he was
calm
and sorrowful
would you also
him as
sincere
when he said
how could we end this
my first impression was yes it was
sincere gesture i can tell you if he was
sincere
or if he was just trying to lure us out
of the house okay and he mentions the
term war correct
he did and
were you aware
and did you personally see
lauren canorax
it's a compound question okay
did you
see
lauren canorax
use
of the term going to war
numerous times throughout
the last
two or three weeks leading up to the
incident
i have no context to it nor do i
remember specifically anything you're
talking about
now
did your dog
michael barrasso
when we were on the concrete patio the
dog got out
because i didn't have time to close the
door as i was
trying to control the situation so yes
at some point i noticed rosie when
me and michael are tied up on the ground
and i'm subduing subduing them
did you see rosie biting michael marisol
i believe rosie bit me as well
did you see rosie fight michael
barrasson
yes
did did you see rosie bite michael
barisson
in his inner groin area next to his
genitals
uh he was face down so i couldn't
no
i couldn't imagine how that would happen
but
now
did you break
michael's arm
i did
did michael pass out at any point in
time during this beating
so mike i mean in addition to what he
already testified about
when he put him in the chokehold you
mean after that point in time so oh
after after after the chokehold he's
asking
were you aware that ruth
cox had a gun at the facility
no
now
just a good goodwin
the day before the shooting
when the townspeople were there
at some point
did you take your finger
and form it into a
pistol
pretend like you pulled the trigger
and word
mouth the words to michael barristone
get
ready
not at all
um
i'm going to show you a series of
pictures
800.
852-865
i'm going to show you these photos
just be careful when you view those mr
shellhorn
i think the witness has already said
that he's seen no pictures of the
defendant after this all happened so i'm
not sure
that objection was sustained and
something else mr blancas please
mr goodwin
after the police arrived
you had an opportunity to see
michael barriston they are correct
i don't know
what capacity you're talking about
i did see him there after the incident
yes
and
would you agree with me that his face
was
filled with blood
i think i was more concerned with what
lauren was
i understand
but with regards to your observations of
michael barrisson
would you agree
that his
arm
looked deformed did you see that
i don't know how he looked after i did
see him i did not
assess him is i think what you're asking
for an assessment of what i thought of
michael after the incident okay
i assessed lauren
my last question
the week leading up to this incident
things were extremely
toxic correct
there are tense
can you tell the ladies and gentlemen of
the jury
why
on august 3rd 2019
you were searching
mary has objections
objection judge objection mr blinkist
you have anything else mister blinkist
how long did you recall uh redirect i
think it will be before the lunch break
judge all right that's all right yeah
sure we'll get it done redirect
uh mr goodwin you were asked questions
about when the township officials came
from the property
did you meet with any of the town
township officials
i
recall talking to them and i dropped the
paperwork off at the um the clerk's
office but i'm asking specifically when
they came to the property
did you speak to them i don't believe i
interacted with them were you at the
barn
at any point when they were at the barn
was were you in the area where
michael barrison was
i was in the barns of long island
now
i just wanted to ask you a few questions
about your statement do you still have
that in front of you i do and i believe
that's been marked as defendants exhibit
100 e5
correct that's the statement that mr
bulink has referred to as your official
version of the events
correct
now he asked you at some point whether
you heard the shots
against lauren or saw the shots against
lauren yes do you remember what you
testified to on direct yesterday
uh then i
saw michael shoot lauren
and i'm going to direct your attention
to page 30.
about halfway down the page
you see a line that says sg
so hd in the midway yes does one yes and
it says sg is that detective sasha gould
uh i she's one of the detectives i
talked with
and it says
she asked you so you see him take the
gun out you see him actually firing at
lauren
and your response is yes correct
so you told that to the police on august
7 2019 yes
does it sound familiar that this
statement began at approximately 509
that afternoon
i wouldn't know what time was and if i
direct your attention to page one
if you look at the last paragraph on
page one
does that refresh your memory of
approximately what time that statement
began
i don't think it's inaccurate
do you remember approximately what time
the shooting happened
two o'clock
so you gave a statement to the police
that was recorded
at the police station
approximately two hours after the
shooting
correct
three hours i'm sorry
my math is off
now you were also asked the questions
about
uh
whether you had walked down the stairs
and off the porch do you remember that
question yeah yes
and i think mr bolinkis asked you did
you step off of the porch and down onto
the patio area i think mr blinkers was
confused about this all right hold on
hold on don't don't open on mr malinka's
state of mind all right just answer the
question please thank you
so my question was do you remember the
question about whether you stepped off
the
porch onto the patio area i do
and what was your answer to that
question no
now i'm going to direct your attention
to
i believe page 28
and down at the bottom of page 28
were you asked questions
about when you came
when lauren came to get you
i'm sorry
page 28 page 28 at the bottom at the
bottom what am i looking at
does it say detective sasha gould asked
where are you actually are you still on
the how in the house or you're on the
porch now at this point
and did you respond i'm in i was in the
house i came down the stairs i think i
handed off the phone to lauren
because unintelligible on the phone with
the attorney i walked outside and he
said you know how could we end this you
know looking really sincere i mean
she said on the front porch and you said
yeah
exactly
so you told the police on august 7 2019
that you were on the porch while you
were talking to michael barrasso
and i think the last thing i wanted to
clear up was the question about
whether you went into the house
or stayed on the porch at the time of
the shooting do you remember that series
of questions
yes
and specifically
on page
for example
three
page string page three
okay
in in the beginning probably the fifth
line down to that second uh main
mean paragraph
is that uh a paragraph of your your
statements to the police
that's you speaking
uh
it says rg in the left-hand side yeah
i'm just trying to read it real quick
i'm gonna direct you to where you need
to read i'm just asking yeah that's
that's that's my paragraph so that's you
speaking there right yes and about the
fifth line down do you see on the left
column where it says shot at me
yes
does it say shot at me i kind of ran in
the house and then he started coming in
as well
i didn't i didn't run i didn't ran in
the house just you know because the
incident was going on i didn't know what
to do i ducked in the house and then i
realized like what the hell am i doing
and i kind of turned around
yeah i think
yeah
so did you actually go inside the house
or not
i don't i don't in the house how far
into the house did you go
oh there's a very small room i dove uh
far enough i felt like i was protected
from
uh the shots being fired at me
i just wanted to get behind cover
no further questions all right thank you
and
mr goodwin
did you also say on page 30
i think she ran like around the house
that's in it
mr bolenkas that's not
yeah that's that's not a recross
question and it has to be in response to
what
was brought up on redirect do you have
any questions about what mr shellhorn
brought up no all right
all right you may step down thank you
please don't discuss the case with
anyone in case you have to be recalled
thank you
all right members of the jury we're
going to take our lunch in recess now
hold on i know you're all anxious i am
too but
i just want to get back to that issue
about jurors hearing whispering can i
see by a show of hands the jurors in a
gallery who may have previously heard
some whispering
all right
we have two jurors okay very good um i'm
just going to ask you two to remain in
place if you would because i just want
to speak to you a little bit further
with the attorneys okay the rest of the
jurors you can uh go enjoy your lunch
and we'll see you around 1 30 this
afternoon we have some more witnesses
that the state will call thank you
can you go out and tell them to cut the
feed
i don't want any of this being sent out
and just confirm for me that it's been
cut
you